[Music]
we have this table available we have
some cards
would you like to like to show any joke
I do it oh yeah you have a deck of cards
you have yourself right I do shuffle
them up
alright let's say this in how how
amateur the shuffle convey here yeah I
can barely shuffle two hands well then
use one yeah I just showed yeah okay
all right we're good to go switch decks
with me all right okay yeah no yeah
poker you've heard of like what wild
cards like deuces are wild baseball have
multiple wild cards the other game so
just cut a card that would be the wild
card just cut off half the deck I'm
gonna move there's one card left over
here I can put put out my deck yes we're
not in it there yeah okay
just cut the deck in half here tell when
you got it okay just to make it more red
just say any random number three four or
five seven anything you want six six one
two three four five six
what's that card clan time so the
Queen's will be the wild card okay then
you just shuffle these cards right and
it now have you ever played poker for
money and the missus have you ever
played in the casino or have you ever
wondered when I play in a casino my
getting conned I have lost in a casino
okay so that that thought has crossed
your mind am i getting caught yeah now
I'm gonna show you you just hand me a
randomized deck and I'm gonna do this in
an interesting way and the high state
games they'll cut between every shuffle
because that buries the top and bottom
half of the deck
I'll give the deck a little riffle and
they will people like to cascade the
cards into them give it a cut so I'm
telling you what I'm doing as I do it I
shuffle did everything legit look legit
and not a movie saw was so you're
already in trouble no ocean I'm sure not
a move I saw was was honest not a one I
got a one now show you how fast I could
uncut that deck what's that card that is
the two clubs the two of clubs so
they'll pass the deck to the right to be
cut now the deck is no longer cut so to
be still on top watch again I'll watch
again I'm showing you how fast I can
uncover the deck the deck is no longer
cut yeah that was about a half a second
now you've heard of Texas Holdem I have
him okay well would you let hand if hold
them and then hold them they have what's
called a cut Carter a burn card
therefore the card the deck on a face-up
card now after the fact you're gonna
tell me keep everything off the table
here give me a full day when you're
right
after the fact you tell me how many
people step up to my whole dump table
let's bake your number five or six
because we don't have a lot of room five
to five players one two three four five
two three four five burn and we always
called the flop and what are those three
cards you got the King of Hearts the two
of hearts and the queen of clubs that
deuces are not wild but we did some of
the Queen's was your card yes that means
there's a pair of kings on the table
there's a burn and a turn what's that
card that's a over turn so right now we
have three kings because the queen is a
wild card what's that card that's a clan
right now we have four kings let's go to
our burn card and you're my partner
sitting over here and hand number five
let's see what you have in the pocket
what's that what's that that's a so in
the poker you would have five of a kind
five kings or you'd have a royal flush
depending on how you wanted to play the
hand in other words you kill them you
slotted them beat them with the big time
okay now we shuffle that deck okay I'll
do I'll show you how far I can push the
envelope all right so I'll shuffle this
one I think I think we got two cards I'm
gonna start it up on that one okay
that's your job to make sure that one's
all but jit of it yep
okay and then I'll switch with you there
you go thing and you can make sure
everything is legitimate that one yeah
all right we'll give the deck a cut and
we'll play my favorite game seven card
stud and this would take a couple
minutes to unfold but it's interesting
that we have a deck of cards shuffled by
Tim now we'll say with the same number
of players who wanna sit you choose four
players or five you choose four where do
you want to sit number one number two
number three or number four I'll be in
number one number one right out of the
chute I'm getting ready to I'm doing a
card in slow motion to hand number one
before I continue to take these deck
this deck mix them up don't give me the
whole deck back just pull up any random
that deck and put him in my hands just
do something quickly just a couple of
cards no well more than a couple but
have to get around just a staff so I'm
going to work with whatever you give me
okay Tim just having me back on random
stack of cards we're playing at dealing
card to plan and number two player
number three and player number four your
number one slow motion watched carefully
there's your card and we go player two
three four now we have what I call the
door crush which means the face-up cards
what's that card Jack yes one player two
player three pair for your number one
what's that card ace of clubs or two
number three number four your number one
what's that card is of mix them up make
them a bit more
mix up the entire whatever you're the
boss okay and just have any any part of
that deck you want see you do it
everything you can to screw things up
okay and you just fell okay that's like
five cards less than the last time you
gotta me okay we are player two player
three player four and so far we have
three cards face up yes sir
and what's that card it's a queen of
diamonds wild card what did I do it
again mix them up have me any part of
the deck you want
so you're shuffling cutting you choose
how you chose how many players you chose
where you want to sit you're having any
random part of the deck oh my gosh
getting stingy down to six cards player
two player three player four and we
always called down-and-dirty I'm now
dealing the card off the top to Tim's
first position two three four put that
with the rest of the stack okay now
let's see what you have in your hand
we're playing seven card stud hi shovel
that means high Spade in the hole splits
the money so let's see what you have
what's that card Queen and dies our
queen a wild card so we'll put it over
here and what's that ace of done that
would be a pair of aces here the Queen's
wild with that ace clubs now equals
three aces what's that this is jack of
spades act what's that that's a ten of
Spades ten ten Jack ace what's that
that's the Queen of Spades another wild
card so right now you have four two h's
and two queens right that's right
so right now input
equal four aces in the best possible
hand in wildcard is five aces were
playing high Spade in the hole splits
apart with that yes base of is a space
five ace is the best possible hand you
can get in poker there's five aces you
shuffled you cut you chose how many
players you wanted you chose where you
wanted to sit and you met kept mixing
them up and you didn't even give me a
full deck you you honestly say that
Turner doesn't play with a full band yet
I dealt you the perfect hand in poker
that's regrettable it's incredible
that's yeah that's incredible
amazing all right but that shows you how
far I can push and that particulars and
I know this and I don't mean to sound
boastful cuz it's hard to talk about
when you're asking people asking
questions about yourself it's hard to
talk about yourself and not sound bad
but Vernon when he first saw me do that
I said professor what do you think about
combine this and this and this
Gregory Peck gosh stop not partial I
apparently can't be done
nice you said you said you can't do it
because three reasons one your brain
cameras move respond that fast your
hands cannot be that sensitive and you
would break rhythm with those who put
those all cards back together from this
deck okay he said it's not possible and
I were at the Magic Castle and for 10
minutes i sat there where he was sitting
if the bar and I was standing next to
him and I was depressed for 10 mins I
said they're gone this is the ultimate
this is the perfect way this is the and
I thought and he said it can't be done
then I'll said never remembered but I
can't do it
I said professor come watch my show and
he came out of this show after we goes
right through what the hell were your
daughter now I don't understand what the
hell you were doing I just remember when
you said you can't combine this in this
that's what I'm doing
all right and he goes back tell me I
watch their flocks s and everybody for
the next 18 months every time I was
there you'd have me suffer the cards how
many players you want where do you once
sit watch this watch it over and over a
two years there he goes
star understand
[Music]
you